there's a couple of good ones here the
twenty-two ways to sleeping on the floor
up until recently we've heard a lot of
stories of hardship from the front line
owing to a shortage of PPE masks that
sort of thing can you tell us did it get
bad where you were and what specific as
I do more testing they say they can't
blow cases they're very smart but
they're very via single and in many
cases very bad people and in some cases
very good one is bad but manufacturing
wrapped up and I think those are two
things that we knew we would take care
of as a country the third thing that we
can't manufacture and I've talked about
this before is a doctor or a nurse or
you know essential person that we can't
just manufacture that so ultimately that
ended up being the weakest point for us
on the front lines
we had the TV we had the ventilators in
time but we just didn't have enough
people couldn't get them there fast
enough and one of the things we did is
we sent in the military doctors and
nurses and I think most of you have seen
them and some of you have worked with
him but they did a fantastic job John we
had a lot of the military like we took
the comfort because they didn't need the
ship and we took the comfort and we took
the doctors and nurses and we sent them
all over New York and New Jersey
we took doctors and nurses out of the
Convention Center the Javits Convention
Center and many of them went throughout
New York so we did a job and we weren't
even supposed to have doctors in the
convention center but we ended up
putting there so we had a lot of because
it's true every tower was one of the
toughest things I think it's for enemies
I talk to my colleagues around the
country certainly there are pockets of
areas where PPE is not ideal but this is
an unprofessional
and one time and I've been reusing my
n95 mask for a few weeks now I just
broke out a new one to come here too in
case I needed to wear it to answer your
question earlier we're all code with 19
free we were all tested so we're we're
not socially distant that we're all
negative and we wouldn't do anything to
help at a time and the infection control
measures that we learn ask for one
patient
certainly and I've had several tests
throughout this whole Cove in nineteen
crisis I practice in New Orleans at a
community health center my youngest
patient has been four days old a four
day old infant and so PPE has been
sporadic but it's been manageable and we
do what we have to do we're nurses and
we learn to adapt and do whatever the
best thing that we can do for our
patients to get the job done and get the
care provided and that's what we're
going to continue to do as hope in
nineteen continues sporadic for you but
that's Braddock for a lot of other
people oh no I agree mr. president
because I've heard the opposite I
worried that they are loaded up with
with gowns now and you know initially we
had nothing we had empty cupboards
we had empty shelves we had nothing
because it wasn't put there by the last
administration and I've heard that we
have I just saw it yesterday when
they're making millions of masks a month
in a factory from you know in that case
it was Arizona that's great we have
other factories being built now for
masks and for the most part I have I
mean that was fine but I've heard we
have tremendous supply to almost all
places tremendous supply to important
in that case whose hairs all right it's
the way we did things but - you know in
in - I'm a nursing supervisor where I
work yet
and one of the blessings I got is my
director my assistant director his name
is Dennis hunter he said you know what
you guys take care of Nursing we'll make
sure we have a supply when we all talk
about the fares it makes it so much
worse for us nurses to work we're seeing
the reality of it and but to hear it odd
constantly there's not enough there's
not enough in reality I'm not saying it
I'm not hot so right now I'm in South
New Jersey very close to you so you
don't see that when you hear the story
you know what cuz they're fake news this
way I really appreciate you saying that
it's so nice had you stepped up because
they're fake news no when I when I took
over it's different now I will say this
there was a period of time but between
Russia Russia Russia and all the stuff
that these characters put us through
it's I've done more than any other
president in history of the first three
years as president and you can look at
that from any way you want to look at it
from rebuilding the military to cutting
taxes to getting rid of regulations at a
level that nobody's ever come close to
to saving you second Amendment which is
under siege by the way so you know we've
done but I really appreciate you safe
and that was really beautiful and you're
right Jeff and the reason that we did
such a good job is because we were able
to that we have factories all over doing
masks and building our own mess and
doing them because a lot of countries I
don't want to be specific but they sent
us mass which were total garbage and
they were defective and they sent us
other equipment which was defective and
so now we're building our own mass we're
doing our own mass we're making them by
the millions
and Honeywell in Arizona yes that it was
a case in point and that was some scene
I've never seen anything like it and I
didn't realize as they put different
layers and then they put it together and
each layer is a different function I
mean you know it's not just like taking
a thing and wrapping it as we said
perhaps you can do in certain conditions
but certainly not inside of a hospital
but no we we ended up we had an empty
cupboard and now we have full coverage
and we have ventilators and we have us
as put layers they don't believe in such
big testing Deborah I mean you know you
have some people that want to test
everything 15 different ways mostly
that's the media because they know you
know certain things can't be done but we
have tremendous testing right now when
you see that chart I don't have it with
me now I guess they have it someplace in
the room well when you see the chart
that I put up yesterday as I was
interviewed by one of your friends on
ABC that chart says it better than
anything I can say you saw the line
going
we're like a rocket ship everyone else
is down here in testing and then all
they do is complain about the testing so
look you get used to that but I really
appreciate the fact that what you said
and we do have way of great and not only
do we have great equipment but we have
the the the quality of what we have is
far better than anything that we're
getting it because we see what comes in
the quality of the gowns the quality of
the masks we have as of today we've got
1 billion gloves gloves would be whoever
heard of such a thing
at the beginning we had done you know
when this all started we had none it's
one of the greatest mobilizations it's a
war and it's one of the greatest
mobilization so it's been it's been very
successful
about reopening the initial four catus
showed that the real decline in the
infection curve would be about June the
first I'll just address one part of that
that the school should open one thing
you should be careful of is when
instructors are over sixty especially if
they have a problem that you should pick
up but the school should definitely open
in my opinion could you answer the other
part ever
so the I think you're referring to the
model that looks at mortality talked
about vision and then mortality is very
variable that's model has gone from
sixty thousand not 134 thousand
obviously we track mortality very
closely you can see the rate of new
hospitalizations has gone dramatically
down and so we're following that and
mortality very closely and so we all
know about models and that's why we
follow the data metro by metro and you
know we have represented here New
Orleans that has moved through a very
large peak and has come down the other
side same with Detroit we continue to
watch Chicago very carefully we know
that both Laura Chad and Philadelphia
are still working through a very
difficult time so the country has moved
as individuals and what we are so proud
about is how much the governors are
using testing in a focused way so
they're not just diagnosing the
individuals that come to the hospital
with symptoms they're proactively going
out and testing in nursing homes and
prisons it lasts
[Music]
working very spread because we've been
talking about it for two months but now
finally it's really getting picked up
that there is a symptomatic spread and
that's why governor's using that
strategic testing to ensure that the
most vulnerable those in disadvantaged
areas of the cities in
multi-generational households those in
in group I called that out as a very key
point do you think we'll be in a place
in August where schools at least in some
states will be able to reopen well again
it's a county by county state by state
decision and that's how we're collecting
data and we're hoping and we are asking
all of the states to have a very very
great data system so that every
community member can see what's
happening in their community both
hospitalizations and testing and
unfortunately any mortality so these
decisions can be continuously updated
and we're seeing that we're seeing much
better sites at the state and county
level to really inform the public in a
very clear way open wherever possible
which i think is in much of the country
most of the country no I would say that
until everything is perfect I think that
the teachers that are a certain age
perhaps you say over 60
or diabetes or any one of a number of
things I think that they should not be
teaching school for a while
and everybody would understand that
fully that we understand but other than
that you see how well children seem to
do it's incredible we realize how strong
children are right their immune system
is maybe a little bit different maybe
it's just a little bit stronger
especially they have a problem with
heart he's feeling better see you in
about three minutes
there's a lot stronger a lot stronger
we've learned a lot by watching this
monster thank you very much
[Music]